banderas a media asta velas y el
replique de las campanas en honor a las
vidas perdidas por el cob y 19 en eeuu
el presidente demócrata joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala harris rindieron
un solemne homenaje en la casa blanca
cuando la nación supera la trágica cifra
del medio millón de decesos
colomer que se me manda
hoy pido a todos los estadounidenses que
recuerden recuerden a los que perdimos
ya los que nos dejaron atrás pero
mientras recordamos mientras todos
recordamos también pido que actuemos que
permanezcamos atentos que nos
mantengamos socialmente distantes que
usemos mascarillas que nos vacunemos
cuando nos toque que packs de morelia
eeuu epicentro de la enfermedad mundial
marca un sombrío hito más
estadounidenses han fallecido en un año
por la pandemia que durante ambas
guerras mundiales y la guerra de vietnam
juntas
si bien los estadounidenses son el 4% de
la población global representan el 20
por ciento de los decesos totales por
coronavirus en el mundo y cuentan además
con más de 28 millones de contagios
muchos intentan ahora buscar respuestas
a estos datos que reflejan una falta de
unificación nacional para contener la
enfermedad durante el último mandato de
donald trump
eso no explica como un país rico y
sofisticado puede tener el mayor
porcentaje de muertes y será el país más
afectado del mundo creo que eso no
debería haber ocurrido
pero aunque no y no creo que sea ya
sabes todo donald trump o todo esto y
aquello es una combinación de cosas y
ciertamente la falta de implicación en
la muy muy alta cúpula de la dirección
pese al avance de una campaña que ya ha
vacunado acá
20 de la población las autoridades
proyectan más de 600.000 muertes para el
1 de junio